what do you see in terms of work ethic
in
generation xers or millennials
i'm getting in trouble but i'll just be
honest
um thank god i've seen a few exceptions
hard-working no excuse
there's only there's two kinds of
assistants that come to me to work on my
films
one they're nice kids smart kids
you ask them to do something they go do
it
and then they walk back and they ask is
this what you wanted
the other kid is the kid who
has observed you and your needs
and before you sit in a directing chair
everything you need is there
if you need something else they run to
get it they run back
and they there before you get to and you
get there at six o'clock in the morning
they're at 5 30.
you leave at 9 00 they leave at 10.
you see they they they
they understand the industry and the
fact that
they know they need missionaries so once
they
satisfy my needs i become their
missionary for their next job
they understand it and they get it but
not the majority